ap
[Musique]
un tout
qui tue
[Musique]
de toute façon le spectacle il faut le
faire bien
c'est tout ce qui intéresse à dire que
qui est 300 personnes cinq cent mille
500 ou 5000 c'est la dame en bleu il
vaut mieux partir avec 1000 personnes
debout que 3000 à 6 voilà c'est tout
donc le but de l'opération c'est quel
que soit le nom de personne que dans la
salle c'est de 2,4 chiffre c'est la
partie de boxe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
là
à
on les entend encore c'est ça a marché
nous ce qu'on veut c'est des gens soient
sensibles à la musique qu'on fait de la
manière
on y croise à lire ces gens-là
réagissent pas comme devant un chanteur
qui fait de la guimauve heures parce que
les chanteurs font pas de lag in mouffe
les musiciens n'en font pas non plus à
en témoigner ce soir j'espère c'est
s'entendre avec sa spirale
les gens qui regardent d'habitude les
émissions de télé comme celles là sont
concerne la musique ont fait c'est de la
vraie musique rock française et que
c'est pas d'la musique rock anglo saxon
avec des mots en français
voilà c'est à nous très latin salut je
vais changer d'optique york merci bien
au chaud
[Musique]
ça me fais pas ça m'angoisse pas
tellement d'être là j'étais plus
angoissés avant d'arriver que quand n'y
étant finalement je trouve que ça paraît
assez dérisoire donc c'est l'école libre
on a tant parlé toute l'année c'est ça
l'école libre ces nombreux curieux ça
c'est surtout ce coin là et surtout l ue
oui c'est passé un énorme chahut et
organisé de rébellion on a ou le
carrelage qui l'a en fait on avait
rempli de flotte dire que ça faisait un
ou d'une couche d'un ou deux centimètres
d'eau parce que le surveillant qu'on
avait à l'époque se promener la nuit
effectivement en pleine nuit quand il
est arrivé que la marché dans luz avec
la mousse et on l'a entendu dans tout le
dortoir ont été mis en était vraiment
minot on était petit et il nous aller
nous avait fait mettre à genoux sur le
parquet pendant deux heures en demandant
à celui qui avait organisé sa de se
dénoncer
et comme c'était moi je suis dessus
dénoncé il m'a fait rester deux heures
en verre comme ça comme s'il me voyais
pas aller à la tribune après je sais que
c'est vous tasser à sénou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ira
j
[Musique]
j'avais surtout son frère aîné qui est
une l'aise et j'ai connu comme ça un
petit peu
daniel ne pas me souvenir qu'il y avait
à ce moment là de longues études pour
les internes et que quelquefois le
surveillant d'études étaient contents de
l'envoyer par nos petits plats on en
voit souvent la visite et les
professeurs qui étaient dans la maison
on se croit qu'ils allaient voir les
coudes en particulier à ce moment là un
petit peu et il faisait le tour quelques
vacances à des professeurs à leur dire
bonjour il y avait déjà à ce moment là
une forales je passe très bien je
suppose et il y avait une promenade à la
fin de l'année on allait à
saint-sébastien généralement et on
retour je me rappelle je vois les faits
c'est le souvenir que j'ai il avait 11
ans avaient mis en joue pas en vedette
on avait fait chanter me mais je ne sais
quoi filer vers déjà le goût du
spectacle tension de sens mais pas un
petit peur en valeur jusque là mon
frangin la tête aux bolides à la coupe
se veut bol c'est
comme ça les arrange de quelques qu'on
avait il ya un petit boulot là le petit
boulon lui piquer ses provisions
quand on était au réfectoire lui piquer
tout on le trouvait trop gros alors dit
qu'il fallait qu'il arrête
et là c'est moi je veux que je te fasse
quoi toi je te la montre comme on dit tu
veux voir ma photo tu veux la voir là
non tu peux pas faire ça
[Applaudissements]
vise les pompes essaye de prendre que
les chaussures la tête sujet j'avais la
capitale santiago
c'était déjà par les eaux petit tout
petit déjà
ça veut dire ça pourtant
tu l'as vu la non tu peux pas
freins planque où une professionnelle
voit la tronche de cake c'est moi dans
mon dans mon cartable il y avait
peut-être début je m'en rappelle plus
j'ai pas de souvenirs d'enfance donc
c'est casse bonbons en plus les
souvenirs d'enfance
j'ai appris les mêmes choses que tout le
monde j'ai laissé ce qui me plaisait pas
et j'ai gardé ce qui me plaisait c'est
peut-être ça qui fait la différence avec
certains
est ce que c'est que ça mais ça c'est
une photo de toi en plus non c'est toi
t'as communion c'est ça ma communion
bien sûr que oui l école de cure et on
était obligé de faire la communion bien
sûr j'ai gagné une montre ce jour là
j'avais pas qu'on gagne et des trucs
d'accord parce que si j'avais su qu'on
gagne et détruit qui leur fait plusieurs
fois ensuite j'ai changé d'école et je
me suis retrouvé à pau dans le sud-ouest
et je ne pensais pas du tout faire de la
musique firme et frère chanter ensemble
souvent mais moi ça ne me branchait pas
trop en fait j'écoute et la musique des
autres j'écoutais les stones se faisait
partie des du clan des durs c'est à dire
ceux qui disaient que les stones c'était
mieux que les beatles alors qu'en fait
j'ai écouté autant les beatles une fois
que j'étais chez moi mais moi je voulais
faire des études de ce que j'avais déjà
presque fixé de faire le droit sciences
politiques et des trucs comme ça et mais
ça me savais pas si je me suis soigné
après une manière assez profonde et
j'avais dans mon idée l'utopie des
députés de représenter quelque part ma
région ou quelque chose comme ça je me
définis c'est ce genre de trucs
en fait c'est à dire de faire un métier
public et puis finalement j'ai trouvé le
discours de de ceux qui étaient dans ce
métier public nous sommes musiciens
tellement emmerdant est tellement
identique et vulgaire que j'ai préféré
prendre des musiciens pour camoufler
veine discours direct mais mais c'est
tout cher je me suis mis à la musique
tard à faire
invité à 16 17 ans parce que justement
il y avait eu à cette époque là mai 68
et comme j avais été mêlé de près en
tout cas dans mon coin
ben j'ai été déçu en voyant arriver les
les soi disant révolutionnaire qui
venaient nous tenir finalement le même
genre de discours que les hommes
politiques de l'époque et c'est à dire
c'était alain ges marc sauvageau cohn
bendit et ses acquis qu'ils faisaient
des tournées en province comme les
chanteurs quoi et alors se faisait une
image de absolument extraordinaire et
puis finalement quand on les voyait
arriver mais on entendait que des
conneries quoi que des bêtises ça m'a
complètement démobilisée j'ai eu un
petit peu de dégoût tout comme à ce
moment là mon frère faisait médecine et
avait une guitare il a laissé tomber la
guitare et continuer la médecine et moi
j'ai arrêté mes études j'ai pris sa
guitare a cédé sous
j'ai passé de longues périodes de ma vie
sans en avoir sans être pauvre on enfin
sans être riche non plus dans une
famille normale j'aurais vous et puis
depuis quelques années j'en ai un peu
même plutôt beaucoup mais pas
milliardaires mais bien disons que je
suis pas mal placé pour faire la
différence entre les deux il ya un adage
on trouve ridicule qui dit que l'argent
ne fait pas le bonheur mais moi je crois
que c'est vrai par contre c'est une faut
pas nier c'est que je crois que le large
en est le plus bel anesthésique qui est
pour le malheur mais c'est ça reste un
anesthésique et c'est aléatoire
c'est tout ce que j'en pense c'est
chanter qui m'a fait gagner de l'argent
c'est mon talent and co alors ça d'abord
je voudrais faire un petit rectificatif
les chanteurs gagner beaucoup d'argent
les chanteurs qui marche et ce qui ne
marche pas on gagne pas la deuxième
chose effectivement c'est que ça fait on
pourrait presque faire une subdivision
comme ça tiens par exemple est de dire
que c'est vrai qu'un tube fait
rapidement une chanson c'est vite fait
enfin moi je les fais assez vite
elle est surtout les textes d'ailleurs
jeu parce que j'aime pas passé beaucoup
de temps dessus mais un tube qui me
rapporte beaucoup d'argent finalement
c'est vrai fait fait beaucoup de choses
à beauregard le studio d'enregistrement
on va faire ça il ya dans le studio
d'enregistrement évidemment les gens qui
vendent des magnétos pour que le
chanteur enregistre alors donné un peu
de sous il ya ceux qui fabriquent la
borne pour qu'on enregistre dessus
maintenant plus comme ça progresse de
jour en jour il ya des gens qui peuvent
arrêter les nouvelles techniques
la technique numérique en digital et ses
cartons un peu de souci et à l'assistant
et à l'ingénieur il ya les musiciens bon
il ya la maison de disques si je gagne
pas beaucoup d'argent c'est que ça
marche pas donc si ça marche pas la
maison de disques ne peut pas payer ses
employés
donc je vais sur ma part d'argent donné
de l'argent la maison disque beaucoup je
dit pas quel est le taux de mon contrat
mais comment ça leur rapporte des sous
alors on va donner d'argent la maison
pour les employés je crois que c'est
barclays en plus il ya quelque chose
comme 200 employés que je comme ça dans
leurs données allons-y donné il va
encore un peu comme un peu oui
allez bon ça ça fait ça il ya des gens
qui font la fabrication après dudit les
usines
thaci relevé acheter la matière après
faut payer les gens bon il faut payer
les machines qu'il faut presser les dix
dexter nuit tu me le dis dans ma vie
avant nachi tient à 21,4 pour toi un
petit peu pour les coupables
bon l'argent que je gagne moi c'est à
dire ceux qui restent fois qu'on a
donnée le reste eh ben on peut
considérer que pratiquement à longueur
d'année il ya en permanence une
fourchette assez large entre 10 et 30
personnes que je paye moi lire les
musiciens quand on a tourné en les 25 il
ya le mec qui nous loue les camions
celui qui nous loue les quarts se dire
ça n'arrête plus je suis pas en train de
faire c'est un raisonnement capitaliste
un que je pousse là c'est à dire que
c'est les riches qui font vivre les
autres soit disant je sais pas un
raisonnement qui me tient à coeur mais
il ya des vérités qui sont
incontestables c'est tout mais il faut
en rigolait il faut rigoler c'est tout
seul et puis comme j'ai toujours il ya
cinq ans ça marchait pas et personne me
demandais comment j'allais et si dans
cinq ans ça marche plus je prendrai deux
derniers billets et chaque jour jean
déchiré un petit bout pour le yaourt à
vous pour le machin est absolument la
personne viendra taper à ma porte pour
me demander ce qui se passe alors vous
prenez un poivron morts on notera
d'attaquer la piperade qui est un plat
de mon pays
un espoir et il y avait encore des dix
ans qui saute un peu rompu truc là voilà
aller
j'avais le torchon à l'américaine voilà
mais pour essuyer je prends le poteau
plus grands mais attention au feu est
évident que pendant que j'ai plus le
premier rognon je laisse les poivrons
ira feu relativement forte
et pourquoi s'il vous plaît je vous le
demande parce qu'en fait c'est les
poivrons qui mettent plus de temps à
cuire c'est pour ça que bon les merdes
j'aime ça parce que c'est les oignons
c'est en train de mourir alors comme je
vous le disais maintenant je mets le
petit piment pour un petit peu relevé
j'ai du plan français quitte pas trop
vous enlever les graines d'abord parce
que comme vous le savez des grecs de
malaisie permis de couper mais thomas
mich est bien souvent la semaine lundi
sur saab a beaucoup on peut douter avant
mais il semblerait que je parlais que je
préfère ça fait partie de ma vie aussi
un petit peu d'ail ça c'est facultatif
quand ils arrivent puis annulée
ces régimes jusqu'à ce que je puisse
manger à boire un petit peu de sucre en
poudre un chat mais enfin ce n'est pas
fondamental comme je dis toujours c'est
les années où j'avais le plus de points
que j'ai vendu le plus de disques
donc ça veut dire que mon talent est
plus lourd que l'on trouve à fait pèse
plus lourd dans la balance
ce qui me rassure d'ailleurs voilà un
dernier saut parfait et on tombe tout
doucement
et alors le signe pour dire que c'est
bon c'est quand ça commence à ressembler
un truc a déjà écrit bon marché tu
pourras me laisser le sac d'ailleurs
apprécié part en tournée en stop ça
pourrait me faire mais ça me fera déjà
le sac à dos alors là c'est quoi là
c'est un autre disque encore c'est un
noir ah ouais ça je montre alors
ceux ci ceci est mon idole voilà j'avais
passé longtemps son idole ya plein de
gens que que j'aime beaucoup que
j'admire
david byrne talking heads phil collins
genesis yes
mais celui-là c'est peter gabriel c'est
pour moi ce qui est le plus beau c'est
ce que je préfère
si j'avais si j'avais dû être quelqu'un
d'autre après si j'avais pu choisir en
tout cas après choisir moi si j'avais eu
à choisir je me serais choisi moi mais
si on m'avait dit d'en mettre un
deuxième but par ait pas que j'aurais
voulu être peter gabriel ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
l'hérésie
oui
[Musique]
si jamais ça marche pas avec le public
changer le nom du coupable
j'ai pas cherché c'est moi si vraiment
ça marche pas avec les gens je dirais
qu'on sait c'est ce coup et c'est ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est comme ça alors
donc l'angoissé purement technique
c'est vrai bon t'as vu on a des stores
des soutiens on a toujours parlé tri
fonctionne pas comme ces déclarations
des ordinateurs en sicile ordinateur
tombe en panne c'est une catastrophe si
les tricks se dérègle s'il ya deux ans
on voit ici le super trouper est tombé
en panne en face lire l'éclairage deux
phases dont il a fallu utiliser toutes
les coupes à la place ça quand je suis
sur scène ça ça me fout les boules tueur
je suis pas vraiment bien ça dure deux
minutes parce qu'à ce moment là comme
les mecs qui sue qui jouent avec moi
savent que je suis pas à mon aise
ils vont mettre les bouchées doubles et
ils vont le soutenir et puis hop c'est
cher c'est un groupe manière dont je
suis pas tout seul disons qu'il ya
toujours un certain angoisse pour le
matériel que ce que l'on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'un panne de deux camions mais
dix ans que j'ai toujours entouré par
une équipe formidable qui s'occupe de
manière à masnières parfait de tous ces
problèmes ce qui était surtout important
c'est qu'on dit avait fait avant d'être
ingénieur du son en studio avait fait
beaucoup de scène avec des groupes
anglais et puis ensuite il avait été à
bonne école au château d'hérouville avec
des gens comme ken scott
à l'époque de walton jeunes étaient
venus faire un double album qui a marqué
la carrière bully helton qui était qui
s'appelait goodbye yellow brick road et
comme je n'avais pas du tout envie de
faire des disques français
j'irai à la française s'il ya peut-être
des fois la va vite j'étais content de
découvrir quelques uns des mes débuts
qui comprennent que j'avais envie
d'essayer autre chose de faire de
d'expérience dans le son on a évolué
ensemble avec andy m'a appris des
milliards de choses dirais qu'il est un
peu mes mains et ma tête
moi je bafouille quelques idées j'essaie
de de définir ce que j'ai dans ma tête
et
on dire à toutes les connaissances
techniques requises pour pouvoir
réaliser tout ça alors là entre temps
est venu seul s'adjoindre une tierce
personne qui est jammer mais disons que
on al'intention avec andy est justement
de 2 pouces et ses expériences beaucoup
plus loin mais peut-être que la seule
carrière française que je mène ne suffit
pas avoir une extension suffisante et on
a envie de faire un groupe evans
on va réunir les gens pour faire ce
groupe on est déjà on est déjà 3 c'est
beaucoup c'est pas tout à fait assez on
cherche encore un peu d'autres j'en ai
un guitariste aussi qui va s'adjoindre à
nous qui est un anglais c'est un hasard
c'est surtout un bon guitariste avant
d'être un anglais et on espère qu'on
pourra prouver à certains on est même
sûr de faire bloquer en france aussi on
peut avoir un son exceptionnel différent
et très élaboré très travaillé seulement
et il faut pas faire les disques en huit
jours il faut les faire on voulait faire
avec le temps qu'il faut
ça
ça pour l'époque que c'était bien
aujourd'hui peut-être que c'en est basé
sur comme ça ça fils de marguerite bibi
up
c'en est aussi
et nous savons pas qui a fait ça
vachement bien c'est vachement bien
ça c'est un truc est très rigolo et
notamment dans le milieu de la musique
rock en france c'est à dire que tant que
les artistes anglo-saxons s'ils ont des
voix aiguë c'est pas grave turbo ya
chanté ou bien avant moi
les beatles souvent des voix un peu
particulière sans trafic d'ailleurs j'ai
enfin je sais il suffit de vouloir les
cités pour pu les trouver mais à
beaucoup de gens le chanteur de queen
chanteur de supertramp du chanteur
police sting chante très très où est
alors quand c'est les anglais ou les
américains ça va ça n'attaque pas à la
virilité française il faut arrêter tous
ces trucs là je dirais que je suis ce
que je suis j'ai la voix que j'ai j'ai
la musique rock ou le rock'n'roll c'est
par là dessus que ça juge le rock c'est
la sueur c'est rien d'autre que ça peu
importe la manière dont on transpire ce
qui compte c'est de transpirer c'est ça
que je dis c'est que les paroles seul
n'ont pas d'importance sinon mettrai pas
de la musique avec c'est un cercle
vicieux je dire que quand je dis ça je
pense notamment aux anglo saxons c'est à
dire les disques qui sortent ici auquel
personne entraves que dalle finalement
c'est pour ça que ça me fait rigoler
parce que les les gens une fois de plus
de la presse spécialisée ont une
exigence vis-à-vis des textes français
qui me paraît complètement délirante
le snobisme n'y en a pas
tu sais je dire que je travaille avec
des anglais des américains mais je
travaille aussi avec des français je
travaille dans des studios anglais
écossais j'ai aussi travaillé dans les
studios et espagnols aux baléares et les
ça change rien au problème
je moi je travaille avec des musiciens
je me fous du pays d'où ils viennent
justement est ce qui me gêne dans toute
cette situation de snobisme c'est
qu'elle vient pas de moi
elle vient des gens qui seraient censés
nous aider populaire ça veut dire en
fait pour les gens qui sont cinq ans pas
mauvais esprit que ce qu'on fait touche
un grand nombre de gens alors je prends
l'exemple le plus typique pour moi
depuis depuis les quatre ou cinq
dernières années c'est un groupe comme
police qui était effectivement un groupe
populaire au sens propre du terme
ça veut dire que moi quand j'ai vu
police au bourget quand j'ai vu police a
à biarritz dans divers endroits comme ça
je vais beaucoup au spectacle eh bien
j'ai vu dans le public il est le public
habituel de la musique rock mais j'ai vu
aussi plein d'autres gens pleins pleins
de gens ça veut dire que il doit
sûrement y avoir en france risque de
choquer certaines oreilles des gens qui
ont mes disques qui ont des disques de
police aussi et qu'ils ont peut-être
aussi les disques de michel sardou pour
être provocateur moi ni l'un ni l'autre
je fais chanteur de musique pop en état
de marche pour le fait marquant
et c'est tous les autres font penser
qu'ils veulent façon je dis toujours que
je suis je suis hypermétropes pour ce
qu'ils savent face à dire je vois pas
bien de près et que je suis trop près de
moi même pour me voir et pour en parler
donc moi je suis ce que je suis et les
autres en font ce qu'ils veulent
ça
pourquoi merci bien aimé
[Musique]